Tìm yêu mại ngàn quan xác, em trần thấy
Bình xe nhìn bên của không dây
Mưa nào, bây quý này xe
Nhưng, ra
Đó áo, đái
Đói đái đái đái đái đái đái
Bình xe nhìn bên của nào, đái đái
Bình xe nhìn bên của nào, đái đái đái
Bình xe nhìn bên của không dây, bây lần nhau
Đói xuống
Ê, như bình xe nhìn bên của không dây, bình xe nhìn bên của không dây
Trời thanh
Để có khu đời cho thanh
Dạ, có khu đời mà giảm
Đi lúc này
Tư, thông, qua, khu đời cho thanh
Ê, mà cái bây lỗi
Thì, tư, thông, mà bùy, tiền
Đi lúc này
Sình ra một xuất nghiệp đậm
Cảm ơn
Sất nghiệp đậm
Cảm ơn này
Sình ra, zong, niệp, cảm ơn
Hôm nay, cái cái bé
Ghi biết, cái đại hợp
Cảm ơn
Bây giờ, bây giờ
Nếu cái thàng mờ rời
Cái thàng dây dàng mờ rời
Sình ra không chuyển đậm nữa
Cái cái thàng dây dàng mờ rời
Rời, dương ra không chuyển đậm nữa
Dì, cách dễ tất của không dây này
Không thay đổi
Cảm ơn từ bây của anh
Hôm nay ố
Không nổi
Rộn, anh phát
À, phía của anh ở dân anh
Rừng nặng, không có ngại điện không có ngồi.
Đừng có không ngồi.
Đừng không có không đổi có vết là không xin ra xuất biển đằng cảm ứng có vết có vết.
Giang ngồi.
Cặn khu dời.
Và lúc lại thì tí viện về xe,
外 chờ với vải xuống không.